[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur tv 78 nous sommes
le mardi 7 juillet c'est une édition
spéciale qui vous est proposée ce soir
par la rédaction
voici le titre principal à l'entrée de
nadia et au gouvernement livre line oise
a été nommé ministre délégué chargé de
la ville auprès de la ministre de la
cohésion des territoires jacqueline
gourault à la passation était prévue en
fin d'après-midi nadia a démissionné de
sa fonction de député des yvelines et
des élections législatives partielles
devront être organisées dans la 11e
circonscription du département et
réactions et conséquence à suivre dans
cette édition
et à la fin de cette émission nous
parlerons également du baccalauréat les
résultats de cette édition un peu
particulière ont été révélées
aujourd'hui elle met direction tout de
suite le ministère de la cohésion des
territoires avenue de ségur dans le 7e
arrondissement de paris nadia est donc
nommé ministre délégué chargé de la
ville et la passation de pouvoir était
prévue à 18 heures sur place nous
retrouvons quelques minutes avant cette
cérémonie nicolas landry écoutez grégory
la passation de pouvoir va commencer
d'ici quelques minutes dans le bâtiment
derrière moi au 20 avenue de ségur à
paris julien de normandie ministre en
charge de la ville et du logement auprès
de la ministre de la cohésion des
territoires et des relations avec les
collectivités territoriales va rejoindre
le ministère de l'agriculture
il transmet le témoin à nadia ministre
délégué en charge de la ville député de
la 11e circonscription originaire de
trappes elle va s'occuper de la
politique de la ville un sujet que
l'illinois se connaît bien puisque à
l'assemblée nationale elle était vice
présidente du groupe d'études ville et
banlieue
la politique de la ville c'est une
action assez globale qui concerne les
quartiers prioritaires l'objectif c'est
de lutter contre les inégalités sociales
et urbaines en passant par des
dispositifs sur le social l'emploi la
culture la sauter ou encore le
développement économique des sujets
qu'elle a pu toucher notamment dans sa
circonscription dans les communes de
trappes ou la verrière merci nicolas
landry sur place au ministère de la
cohésion des territoires avec or ils
iront aux moyens
nick et nous reviendrons plus longuement
sur cette cérémonie de passation dans
notre édition de demain mercredi l'alibi
noise nadia s'est donc vu confier le
ministère délégué à la ville hier lundi
elle fait partie de la nouvelle équipe
gouvernementale autour du tout récent
premier ministre jean castex une novice
en politique il ya encore trois ans
mathilde et demi a retracé son parcours
de sa candidature aux dernières
législatives
jusqu'à sa nouvelle fonction
ministérielle
la trappiste nadia et député de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines a été nommé
ministre délégué à la ville dans le
cadre du remaniement du gouvernement du
premier ministre jean castex
elle s'est exprimé ce lundi 6 juillet
sur les réseaux sociaux se disant prête
à relever le défi
révélé en 2017 au moment des
législatives dans la bague la république
en marche après l'élection du président
emmanuel macron cet ancien cadre dans la
banque s'engage en politique en créant
le comité femmes en marche avec macron
issus de la société civile la trappiste
se lance aux élections législatives
la même année pour la 11e
circonscription l affront de benoît
hamon candidat génération et jean michel
fourgous investi par les républicains
les deux précédents député de la
circonscription au second tour des
élections elle est élu avec 52 96% des
voix contre 47,0 4%
pour jean michel fourgous à 27 ans elle
devient députée des yvelines
je suis effectivement extrêmement
satisfaite des du résultat après après
-selon semaine de travail ces longues
semaines ou tous suis allé à la
rencontre de nous de nos concitoyens et
c'est aussi une grande fierté
aujourd'hui pour moi d'en arriver là au
sein de l'assemblée nationale
elle devient membre de la commission des
finances et fait partie du groupe
d'étude villes et banlieues en tant que
vice présidente aux finances
pour son nouveau poste de ministre
délégué à la ville auprès de la ministre
de la cohésion des territoires
elle pourra s'appuyer sur cette
expérience une expérience de terrain
lorsqu'elle travaillait sur les
questions politiques de la ville
notamment à trappes et à la berrière de
villes de sa circonscription
ce lundi 6 juillet en apprenant sa
nomination au gouvernement elle a
démissionné de son poste de député des
élections législatives partielles seront
donc organisées pour élire son
successeur
laon nadia et que nous n'avons pas eu
encore par téléphone un agenda vous
l'imaginez chargée en cette journée de
prise de fonction la passation avec son
prédécesseur et julien de normandie qui
par lui au ministère de l'agriculture
était prévue ce mardi
à 18 heures avec nous tout de même pour
une première réaction pire luce mon soir
bonsoir
vous êtes le référent départemental de
la république en marge des yvelines déjà
est ce que vous avez eu la chance de
l'avoir
la députée l'ex député désormais nadia
est ce que vous avez pu avoir c'est ma
réaction
non je n'ai pas eu au téléphone le vent
genre et un petit message pour la
féliciter lille alors quand vous avez
appris hier 7 cette nomination comme
ministre délégué en charge de la ville
quelle a été votre réaction vous en tant
que référent départemental de la
république en marche mon côté la
récompense de son travail
c'est un sujet qui lui tient beaucoup à
coeur sur lesquels elle a beaucoup
d'engagement du coup je suis assuré de
la voir j'ai dit elle devient donc
ministre délégué chargé de la ville
auprès de jacqueline gourault qui est
ministre de la cohésion des territoires
vous vous le disiez elle connaît ses
sujets c'est un bon choix elle qui a
oeuvré pendant trois ans dans cette 11e
circonscription des yvelines on le sait
concernés par cette thématique de
politique de la ville avec des communes
comme trappe comme la verrière c'est une
expérience de terrain qu'elle va pouvoir
mettre à profit dans ce ministère
maintenant oui je pense que c'était un
élément déterminant dans le fait qu'elle
était calé dès choisi pour ce poste aux
responsabilités très importante quand on
connaît l agilité qui accueille
actuellement dans beaucoup de quartiers
de communes des yvelines et de france
sur des décennies d'aidés d'accès au
travail qu'elles sont son expérience de
terrain ça ça c'est c'est primordial
quand on regarde plus généralement la
composition du gouvernement qui est
aussi cette cette expérience de terrain
il faut pas forcément des personnes qui
sont on va dire des professionnels de la
politique aussi des gens issus de la
société civile c'est en tout cas le pari
annoncé par au début par la république
en marche intégrer ces personnes de la
société civile elles ont cette
expérience de terrain nécessaires
écoutez ça maintient un équilibre dans
ce gouvernement où
on conserve les personnes qui sans gain
à leurs postes qui est qui travaille
très bien comme comme jean yves le drian
en france parmi vous vont faire entrer
de nouveaux visages effectivement les
personnes plutôt ici de la société
civile qui viennent apporter une
expérience une vision approche que ce
soit des élus locaux des professionnels
des représentants de syndicats c'est
c'est important de savoir ce à la fois
cette fraîcheur dans la vision de la
politique et en même temps cette
compétence et cette expérience sur les
sujets parfois très techniques
alors cette nomination a entraîné la
démission de deux nadière son poste de
député des yvelines on aura l'occasion
d'en reparler tout à l'heure puisque une
législative partielle va devoir être
organisées sur cette 11e circonscription
si vous devez dressé en tant que
référent départemental
un bilan de ces trois ans passé par
nadia et comme député des yvelines quel
est il ce bilan dans cette 11e
circonscription
écoutez c'est toujours compliqué de
laisser le bilan d'un député dans sa
circonscription parce que on me salue un
détecteur à travailler ses 10 et fall à
la fois son ca sa prescription aux le
contact avec la population des relais
vers le version de travail législatif
qui était l'autre moitié
je pense que la meilleure le meilleur
bilan qu'on puisse faire c'est de voir
si la personne est candidate à sa
réélection si elle est élue après c'est
une question de ressenti son bilan l'ex
attifel et dont elle a été désignée par
ce fait à plusieurs propositions dois je
pense qu'on peut dire de ce point de vue
là c'est un moment et on va parler dans
un instant de ses prochaines
législatives partielles qui vont être
organisées sur cette 11e circonscription
rester avec nous pierre luçon on va
écouter à présent d'autres réactions qui
ont été collectées par manon varaldo
investi par la république en marche
nadia est élu député dans la 11e
circonscription des yvelines en jouant
2017 ses collègues députés dont le
département salue sa nomination comme
ministre délégué à la ville très très
heureuse pour nadia et que je connais
bien puisque nous avions fait notre
campagne des législatives
ensemble donc également j'ai été très
fier de voir qu'une personne jeunes
motivés dynamiques travailleuses et bien
aujourd'hui et est nommé ministre d une
très très bonne nouvelle d'avoir une
parlementaire
une femme de trappes qui devient
ministre délégué ça c'est évidemment une
très grande fierté pour les yvelines et
puis pour eux pour son parcours je
trouve que que c'est amplement mérité
la deuxième raison c'est que on a enfin
séparé à la fois le logement et la
politique de la ville puisque du temps
de gildan normandie il y avait cette
grande difficulté ou là le dossier
logement et le dossier politique de la
ville était sous sa responsabilité
parmi les élus de la 11e circonscription
celle de nadia et la maire de saint cyr
l'école espère que la nouvelle ministre
sera plus à l'écouté des acteurs de
terrain et des problématiques
rencontrées
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui lui
tenait à coeur on a eu à plusieurs
reprises l'occasion d'échanger sur le
lait politique de la ville sur les
difficultés qu'on pourrait rencontrer je
vous souhaite bonne chance et je lui
demande de ne pas oublier de partir qui
n'est pas le plus politique de la ville
mais dont elle connaît les difficultés à
trappes
l'ancien maire guy malandain a travaillé
avec nadia et notamment sur les
questions de politique de la ville et de
rénovation urbaine
il se souvient de ses collaborations
avec la ministre natif de trappes
elle avait piloté si je m'en souviens
bien une équipe de députés qui faisait
un rapport sur la politique de la ville
au moment où monsieur borloo préparer
son son document c'est bien mais je sois
nommé lis pas ce que c'est voilà elle
sait de quoi elle parle
et ce sont aussi des éléments
qui est elle a vécu et donc on n'est pas
dans le superficiel ou du théorie au
sein de l'assemblée nadia et avait
notamment travaillé sur les questions de
politique de la ville
en mars elle avait d'ailleurs organisé à
ce titre une table ronde sur l'image des
quartiers populaires pas assez pour
ralliera bemer de sa circonscription
plutôt critique à sa nomination
j'invite la majorité présidentielle en
général le gouvernement le président de
la république le premier ministre à ne
pas utiliser la politique de la ville
comme un gadget à nommer des
personnalités qui en serait issue et se
contenter du symbole nous n'avons plus
besoin de symboles
nous avons besoin de mesures concrètes
n'ajjer nous ne l'avons pas beaucoup vu
sur le terrain soyons honnête elle était
peut-être au travail à l'assemblée
faudrait aller vérifier mais j'espère
que comme ministre elle sera davantage
sur le terrain auprès des habitants de
banlieue qu'elle ne l'a été comme député
de notre ville une nomination que ne
comprend pas également jean michel
fourgous maire d'elancourt et président
de saint quentin en yvelines
dans des propos rapportés par le
parisien c'est une surprise le président
est un homme de théâtre qui choisit les
figures être élu à trappes suffit
manifestement être en vue pour ce poste
encore une fois l'image prime sur la
compétence je n'ai rien contre elle mais
elle manque encore d'une vraie
implantation locale
je lui souhaite juste bonne chance
d'autres réactions sur les réseaux
sociaux notamment celle de karl olive
maire de poissy
un temps pressenti dans le remaniement
du gouvernement un message de
félicitations sur twitter à présent
reste à savoir qui remplacera à nadia et
à l'assemblée madame nadia et nadia
étiez donc nommé ministre délégué chargé
de la ville et qui n'est plus député de
la 11e circonscription des yvelines elle
a préféré démissionner de ses fonctions
parlementaires
son suppléant moussa war où tu aurais dû
siéger à sa place mais il est sous le
coup de problèmes judiciaires une
élection partielle devra donc être
organisé sur cette 11e circonscription
pierre lui ce qui est toujours avec nous
référent départemental de la république
en marche c'était une bonne décision de
démissionner selon vous pour pour nadia
je pense que c'est indispensable
les accusations se sont coulés qu'elle
se trouve son suppléant même s'il faut
évidemment
conservez le chat relance que la plante
son innocence mise en cause le placer
comme une station compliqué pour pouvoir
siéger sereinement et participer au
travail parlementaire
quelle va être la stratégie de la
république en marche dans cette 11e
circonscription
on l'a vu les candidats et les oreilles
n'ont pas forcément eu la faveur des
électeurs dans les communes je pense à
trappes la verrière ou encore dans des
communes comme saint cyr l'école
quelle va être la stratégie c'est de
conserver ce siège de député ce siège de
la 11e circonscription
bien sûr nous notre stratégie est
évidemment de tout faire pour maintenir
la majorité nous majorité présidentielle
et à se concerter avec le comité peut
utiliser ni natif de admis qu'en mars
pour pour essayer d'évaluer la meilleure
stratégie à adopter
mais mais c'est évident que c'est le
résultat des élections municipales qui
n'est pas si mauvais que ça pour nous
vendre département sont les élections
qui sont elles différentes sont tous sur
une partielle ou là on n'a pas
l'ambiance national la participation est
souvent assez basse le défi à relever
sur sur ces élections ça sera avant tout
c'est la participation est fier de
présenter un projet de soutien la
majorité présidentielle et qui saura
plaire aux électeurs et leur donner
envie eux aussi de soutenir ce projet
nous l'a dit il est peut-être vous
commencez à peine à discuter des
potentiellement il ya des noms déjà qui
circulent pour le candidat ce qu'on a
appris aujourd'hui par exemple la
candidature d'autres manas rookie et
conseiller municipal d'opposition à
trappes qui est également conseiller
régional
othman masrouki lors de sa candidature à
trappes affirmé avoir des personnes de
sensibilité en marche aussi sur sa liste
est ce que l'on peut imaginer un soutien
la république en marche à la liste qui
sera présenté à la candidature pardon
présenté par othman nassr ou non je ne
pense pas qu'on va prendre le temps de
la réflexion proposée la nature
c'est où se décidera pas avant merci
pierre luc nord est avec nous et je le
rappelle vous êtes le référent
départemental de la république en marche
dans les yvelines
et je vous rappelle cette information si
vous nous rejoignez nadia et nommer
comme ministre délégué chargé de la
ville la passation a eu lieu tout à
l'heure à 18 ans nadia qui n'est donc
plus député de la 11e circonscription
des yvelines elle a préféré démissionner
de son poste
son suppléant moussa waroux ç'aurait dû
siéger à sa place mais il est sous le
coup de problèmes judiciaires une
élection législative partielle devra
donc être organisées dans les prochains
mois les explications de nicolas landry
une élection législative partielle dans
la 12e circonscription des yvelines la
conséquence directe de la nomination de
nadia ministre délégué chargé de la
ville pour rejoindre le gouvernement
elle a décidé de démissionner de son
mandat à l'assemblée nationale
objectif éviter que son suppléant moussa
waroux ce lui succède au parlement en
août 2019 il a été mise en examen dans
le cadre d'une affaire de trafic de
stupéfiants
sur son compte twitter le principal
intéressé assure que la démission a été
prise d'un commun accord avec nadia et
dans un délai de trois mois les
électeurs de la 11e circonscription vont
être appelés aux urnes pour élire leurs
députés
conseiller municipal d'opposition de
trappes othmana through a été le premier
à annoncer sa candidature sur les
réseaux sociaux
naturellement cette élection législative
partielle elle se fait dans la suite du
combat que je mets la trappe qui la plus
grande île de la circonscription il y en
ad'autres naturellement et pour tout
sept villes de la circonscription moi je
souhaite représenter dignement les
habitants de s'inscrire l'assemblée
nationale ont porté d'abord je lui dis
un combat pour les valeurs de la
république
je me suis toujours positionné comme un
candidat de la droite et du centre est
donc naturellement je suis ouvert mais
je suis allé lui aussi de la droite
républicaine
je ne vais jamais renier et ce sont
aujourd'hui ces valeurs là que je
souhaite porter
de son côté le nouveau maire de trappes
à lire ab souhaite se consacrer à sa
commune en revanche il a son idée pour
représenter la gauche lors de ce
prochain scrutin
moi personnellement je vous le dis je ne
le cache pas je souhaite que benoît
hamon reviennent dans le jeu politique
je souhaite qu'il soit pourquoi pas le
député de la 11e circonscription
malheureusement ça ne dépend pas que de
moi mais je cherchais je tâcherai de le
convaincre et j'espère que les
prochaines semaines des prochains mois
nous donneront l'occasion de re voir
benoît hamon en première ligne je
souhaite que nadia viennent remettre son
titre en jeu
si elle gagne les élections législatives
qui aura lieu d'ici trois mois elle
pourra comme ministre prendre ses
responsabilités et son suppléant ira
siéger à l'assemblée nationale pour le
moment la république en marche n'a pas
pris de décision concernant cette
élection la réflexion est en cours
les sont pour l'instant les candidats
qui vont se manifester
je ne sais pas encore les candidats qui
vont se positionner tout à l'heure j'ai
eus par sms de quelqu'un que je connais
qui est marcheurs de la première heure
qui souhaitent avoir un échange avec moi
parce qu'il souhaite se positionner pour
rappel lors du second tour des élections
législatives de 2010 est dans la 11e
circonscription
nadia et l'avait emporté avec 52 96% des
suffrages devant le candidat les
républicains jean michel fourgous et
vous l'avez vu dans ce sujet une
première déclaration de candidature pour
cette législative partielle dans la 12e
circonscription des yvelines celle
d'hotman nasri et une première réaction
aux déjà suite à cette déclaration de
candidature celle de pierre bédier qui
déplorent dans un communiqué une annonce
solitaire et précipité d'hotman nzru le
président les républicains du conseil
départemental des yvelines estime que la
majorité départementale peut gagner
cette circonscription à condition de
partir
rassembler derrière un candidat solide
pierre bédier qui annonçait également la
tenue d'un comité départemental
extraordinaire des républicains ce jeudi
9 juillet pour préparer la déclaration
la désignation du candidat de la droite
et du centre pour cette législative
partielle
voilà ce que l'on pouvait vous dire sur
cette information je vous rappelle
principal titre de cette édition
spéciale la nomination de la députée des
yvelines nadia comme ministre délégué de
la ville la nouvelle membre
le gouvernement a démissionné de son
poste de parlementaire une élection
législative partielle devra donc se
tenir dans les prochains mois dans la
11e circonscription des yvelines
lui aussi fait partie de la nouvelle
équipe gouvernementale gérald darmanin
ancien ministre de l'action et des
comptes publics est passé à l'intérieur
le désormais pensionnaire de la place
beauvau a choisi les mureaux pour son
premier déplacement et visite au
commissariat où exerçait jean baptiste
salvin ce policier tué avec sa femme
jessica schnyder devant son domicile à
magnanville en 2016 un acte terroriste
perpétuée par un homme se réclamant de
l'état islamique
le ministre de l'intérieur s'est
recueilli quelques instants devant la
plaque commémorative en hommage au
couple deux policiers politique plus
locale à présent avec cette information
révélée aujourd'hui l'élection
municipale à chevreuse est invalidée par
le tribunal administratif le 15 mars
dernier la maire sortante divers droite
à néry le pallec l avait emporté d'une
seule petite voix face à son adversaire
sébastien à cattaneo qui avait déposé un
recours il semblerait qu'un bulletins
litigieux dans lequel le vote on avait
glissé par erreur sa carte d'électeur a
été finalement non comptabilisé ramenant
les deux candidats à égalité
et rappelez vous c'était il ya un peu
plus d'une semaine le second tour des
élections municipales a livré son
verdict à plaisir le conseil
d'installation s'est déroulée vendredi
au palais des sports de la ville
arrivée en tête au scrutin des
municipales joséphine coleman ce berger
était la seule à se porter candidates
celle lors de la séance elle a été réélu
pour un nouveau mandat obtenant 29 voix
sur 39 de son conseil municipal ses deux
adversaires au municipal patrick jeantet
ray à nice joël prix ou hasseni
constitueront deux groupes d'opposition
de son côté joséphine coleman ce berger
va se concentrer à présent sur les
projets en cours les propos sont
recueillis par mélanie poti la maison
médicale inquiets une maison médicale
aujourd'hui déjà intégré dans l'hôpital
mais on a aussi les cols du vélib ou
avec self mais on a aussi le parc à la
mare au sol
on a aussi le parc des quatre saisons à
développer et puis tout le travail
autour du pmu du centre bourse et ce
sont des gros dossiers qui ont déjà
commencé on pourrait dire mais il n'y a
pas de nouveauté dans votre programme
s'il ya des nouveautés puisque on va
développer davantage les espaces verts
on a donc s'est rendu compte que pendant
cette période de confinement il y avait
un vrai bonheur à retrouver le chant des
oiseaux le calme et la sérénité donc on
va essayer de tendre
parce que plaisir deviennent encore plus
une ville verte vraiment une opposition
constructive à l' écoute attentive des
plaisirs oise et des plaisirs mois nous
on priorise les besoins toujours et on
adapte les moyens quand on peut c'est ce
qu'on aurait fait s'il avait été élu
majoritaire les six ans qui viennent
vont être cruciaux les mois qui viennent
après la crise sanitaire que nous venons
de vivre vont se transformer
vraisemblablement crise économique est
en crise sociale
nous devons être là nous devons être
présents nous devons être attentifs et
pourquoi pas soudés sur un certain
nombre de combat commun à condition
d'être entendu patridge inter qui a
décidé de démissionner de la présidence
de son groupe d'opposition qui laisse à
sa colistière sandrine carneiro prochain
conseil municipal dès vendredi à plaisir
avec le vote du budget conseil
d'installation vendredi également du
côté des clayes sous bois avec
l'élection de philippe guy guéguen comme
nouveau maire nicolas hué année claire
frémont arrivé deuxième et troisième au
scrutin des municipales siègeront dans
l'opposition ils ont profité de cette
séance pour revenir sur une conque une
campagne compliquée reportage de manon
varaldo vainqueur du scrutin des
municipales philippe dit guen a été
officiellement élu maire des
clayes-sous-bois lors du conseil
d'installation vendredi 3 juillet il a
également nommé ses neuf conseillers
municipaux
si nous voulons avoir une proximité avec
les questions dans tous les domaines
et comme je les dis être compétents et
réactifs
je souhaitais avoir neuf adjoints parce
que un maire c'est un homme orchestre il
peut pas maîtriser tous les tous les
sujets la seule candidate de la
triangulaire aux élections a souhaité
prendre la parole lors de ce conseil
d'installation dans une ambiance tendue
elle est revenue sur la campagne
agressive et les nombreuses attaques
sexistes de son point de vue il me
paraissait important en effet de revenir
sur cette campagne délétère et c'est
important que je le dise ce soir on a pu
remarquer ce soir que
la seule personne qui a été hué c'est
moi une femme
la réflexion de monsieur le maire je
reconnais la plume ça veut dire qu en
effet une femme je ne suis pas capable
d'écrire ça c'est à l'image de la
compagne une opposition représentée
également par nicolas eu
il a interpellé plusieurs fois le
nouveau maire également sur le
déroulement de la campagne mais aussi
sur la composition de la nouvelle équipe
le renouvellement de l'équipe municipale
on attendra puisque sept des adjoints
élus sont issus de l'ancienne majorité
était déjà adjoint et puis sur
l'ensemble des décisions
délégation de compétence qui ont été
déléguées à monsieur philippe big n est
bien celle ci sont les mêmes que
lors de 19 années précédentes le
prochain conseil municipal se déroulera
à l'espace philippe noiret jeudi 9
juillet à 19h30 avec notamment le vote
du budget et puis dans l'actualité du
jour
aussi le jour j pour les plus de
soixante et onze mille candidats du bac
es 2020 dans l'académie de versailles un
bac un peu particulier cette année avec
le contexte sanitaire les élèves ont été
notées en contrôle continu est les
résultats n'étaient pas affichés devant
les établissements mais les candidats
étaient malgré tout invités à venir
récupérer leur relevé de notes et
réactions recueillies à montigny le
bretonneux par aurélie rose et jules
cachin voilà donc on a le bec moi je
mentionnerai c'est bien là la manche
très bien et 18 de moyenne on peut tout
seul applaudir je savais que j'allais
avoir mon bac mais je savais pas quelle
mention je pensais que j'allais avoir la
mention bien mais du coup j'ai été
surprise j'ai très bien donc je suis
contente admis mention très bien au bac
s et spécial pas qu'ils demandaient pas
trop d'effets enfin un truc qui
demandait de l'effort sur l'annexé
permet pas
l'effort sur une courte période et déçu
par les week-ends de lésion ux directeur
moi j'ai mon bac sans mention j'étais
pas loin de la mention mais voilà avec
10 80 ch est plutôt content quand même
de la voir avec le co vide
c'est vrai qu'on appréhendait beaucoup
comment allaient être les bulletins
comment ça allait se passer donc
on hésitait certains étaient 3 de notre
classe a est passé à la limite donc on
savait pas trop ce qu'on avait pas sans
rattrapage ou pas et bravo à tous les
bacheliers 2020 voilà c'est la fin de
cette édition spéciale merci de votre
fidélité très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]